Hello.
My name is Rich Hyndman, and
welcome to This Week in Android
Development on Monday,
February 10, 2014.
Last week, Paul Carff gave us
an overview of the Google Cast
SDK, while Kevin Nilson gave
us the highlights on the SDK
for iOS.
Krispy went over Cast Receivers
and Google Cast for Chrome--
and yes, that is his name.
Nazmul and special
guest, Richard Fulcher
of the Android design team,
explained User Research.
Nazmul is special guest crazy.
Has one every single week.
Todd had another
Play Games for iOS.
And coming this week,
Fred's mystery DevByte
might actually launch.
I wonder what one thing
Android developers are hoping
will come really, really soon?
Also this week, Katherine
Kuan makes her debut
explaining the Google API
Client and Google Play Services.
My contribution to
the team this week
is to solemnly promise never to
play flap, flap, flapping games
ever again.
And with that, that's
all for this week
in Android Development.
I'm Rich Hyndman, and
my head is an animal.
And once there was an animal, it
had a son that mowed the lawn.